the host of unfiltered dan bongino along
with the co-host of the five geraldo
rivera uh i'll say this to both of you
up front you're both dear friends
under no circumstances do i want to
politicize any of this tonight families
may not even know the status of their
own children at this hour and and yet we
have this race even by the president to
politicize it with i i just find so
offensive
um but at the end of the day we have to
figure out a way to keep kids safe in
school dan bongino i have been
advocating for years people retired
military retired law enforcement
outside the perimeter of every school in
the country
they can donate their time they can we
can offer them tax breaks no income tax
in the state no income tax federally 10
hours a week and we could have every
school in america covered people around
the perimeter people in the halls first
responders there we don't have to worry
about police response times that to me
seems like a no-brainer nobody seems to
find that idea appealing i don't know
any other way to keep kids safe though
then
and metal detectors by the way it it'll
be a lot less than what we're giving
ukraine uh with the 40 billion we're
sending over there
well a couple things uh first it's too
late to not politicize it i respect
where you're coming from but it's not
you doing it sean i mean the president
united states just came out and what
could have been a great healing moment
for all of us to be able to mourn
together i mean he is the president of
the united states he decided to attack
the gun lobby
i i wasn't aware the gun lobby was
involved in this shooting uh were you so
uh again he's the president united
states and in a moment where he could
have been a great healer and unifier he
chose that moment to start screaming at
americans and the gun lobby who had
nothing to do with so
i respect where you're coming from but
those days are over sean uh cutesy time
with these people is over they don't
care now on your second point you know
this is what i did for a living you know
operational security and physical
security on locations and buildings was
a big component of it
pat was a great guest he brought the man
trap is a terrific idea because you
can't get into the second door in the
man trap unless the first door is closed
and they have to operate the second door
meaning if you have a gun they're just
going to trap you between the two doors
and you're not going to go anywhere but
i do disagree with them that we don't
have the personnel he's accurate if you
think of it in terms of active police
officers in the united states yes we
can't take one now and put one at every
single school everywhere and every door
all the time
but what you're thinking where i think
you're more correct is we should expand
that footprint we have a number of
retired law enforcement who have the
skills who may not be able to engage in
foot pursuits but are perfectly capable
of securing say a two or three acre
school somewhere so i think we have to
start to think outside the box the
skills are there the human capital is
there we can do it sean we just got you
know what 20 30 billion dollars in
school funding probably more than that
for the covet thing you know we can't go
out and take care of some of these
schools with security come on we can do
better than this ronaldo i would think
this might be an area of agreement all
three of us can have and that is you
have all of these people trained retired
police retired military you know these
people well and you know what if they
donated 10 15 hours a week at the local
school district and what if we said okay
if you do that we'll give you
a break on your income taxes you don't
have to pay it uh and you don't have to
pay state and local taxes either it
wouldn't even cost us a penny in the end
you know sean i i obviously agree with
you about school security i always have
as the father of five the
grandfather of five
this absolutely makes me sick to my
stomach
i beg those families to accept our
condolences
this slaughter has been something that
will live with all of us it is
absolutely horrible when you think of
those little babies i covered sandy hook
you know it is that again it's these
little children the most vulnerable
innocent beings on earth being
slaughtered
you know the only place you dan and i
diverge is it is not to me irrelevant
that in the last 10 days 30 people have
been killed by two eighteen-year-olds
with assault weapons how can you buy an
assault weapon on your 18th birthday
when you cannot buy a beer it does not
make any sense i've spoken with
president trump about this
why not have a juvenile assault weapons
ban why can't the nra get behind if you
can't buy a beer you can't buy an
assault weapon why is that un-american
how does that violate the second
amendment you know what you know what
the problem with i think the argument is
and i really
my thoughts tonight are really with
these families but i'll answer your
question and i will tell you one of the
it's predicated on a false notion that
evil people with evil intent you have to
be evil to perpetrate a crime and murder
an innocent child
and and the problem is by the very
nature of somebody being that evil
they're going they're not going to obey
they're not going to listen to any laws
because that is coming from their heart
and if your heart drives you to do
something like this
it doesn't matter what's legal or not
legal in their world it matters in your
world i pay all my taxes dan pays all of
his as a matter of fact i usually
overpay just to be sure but the reality
but in this case you're asking people
that don't have a heart and a soul or a
conscience to obey a law they're not
going to obey
two quick points one
we have to protect our children
with the same vigor that we protect the
money in our banks what's worth more the
money or the children why can't we hang
on if we can protect the money then we
surround the perimeter of every school
with law enforcement retirement a
carpenter exactly an entire couple
somebody military somebody yes
armed
armed two absolutely okay absolutely
because i
uh can i jump in and just respond
geraldo wait wait wait because you i
want to respond to your first point you
asked a question i i think i deserve an
answer there you know over a decade in
law enforcement i arrested a lot of
people who had illegal guns and you know
they love your idea for gun laws and new
gun laws you know why because nobody
gives a damn the kids can't buy yourself
especially
can i answer the question right come on
these are two you have these are two
children who bought assault weapons on
their 18th birthday that's why it's so
hard to come on with you because you
just go ahead go ahead i'm trying i
didn't interrupt you man okay listen
let's just be respectful of each other
in this really harsh time i'm just
telling you in my experience yes i don't
want an 18 year old who's incompetent
potentially mentally ill and a homicidal
maniac to have assault weapons you and i
both agree 100 percent and by the way i
don't even agree with the sermon the
term assault weapon but that's for
another day okay that's an unnecessarily
kind of hostile term there's no such
thing there as an assault weapon but
having said that i'm telling you you're
talking about a obviously
psychologically disturbed young man here
who walked into his school and shot a
bunch of school kids
you really believe like he was sitting
there reading a law book beforehand and
i said i know what you're going to say
well maybe we should make it more
difficult to do that but the problem
with that is it's a simple-minded
solution because you also make it more
difficult before the tens and thousands
and hundreds of thousands of others of
18 year olds out there have done
absolutely nothing wrong and would like
to buy a rifle
so what
so what
can you buy a beer answer no why can't
you buy a beer because society and its
infinite wisdom has deepened but you're
not answering my point an 18 year old
why do you believe people that have no
conscience no heart and no soul
parents lost their kids today why do you
believe me make it hard for them why do
you think why do you believe in any way
that those people that are capable of
that evil
are going to obey your laws because i
think you're living in a fantasy world
maybe i am but the nra convention is in
houston on friday you have president
trump you have governor abbott you have
senator cruz all scheduled to speak
don't you think that they should try to
suggest some remedy some be proactive
what are they going to do
other than second amendment
second amendment
second amendment the way the second
amendment is construed now makes me sick
how did how did muskets become aks
wait hold on wait hold on all right i
know overall you've dominated this whole
conversation you're not let anyone else
talk to you rondo you know you're for
the last 30 years of your life you've
been a very wealthy successful guy
nobody disputes that you could go out
tomorrow and buy security if you wanted
to the second amendment makes you sick
why so people like the criminals don't
care about your gun laws they love them
because it keeps law-abiding people
unarmed while they don't give a damn
about your laws i did this for a living
they'd laugh at gun laws and they love
people like you advocating for gun laws
because you can buy armed protection and
they can go in high crime communities
and prey on innocent people you can
never get a hold of a gun because hold
on because they actually obey the law
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else